someone asked me someone asked a good
question Nash to the lecture I have made
this claim that when you have a decision
tree and you expand out each path into a
monomial
take the sum over all of these monomials
that you get a sparse polynomial in
particular I said that if the decision
tree has tea leaves this implied a tea
sparse polynomial computing the decision
tree this isn't quite correct what I
should have done was introduced the
following notation if you have a
function f I should have defined l1 of F
to be the sum of the absolute value of
the coefficients of the polynomial
computing F and there are two easy facts
to see about this taking the sum of
absolute values one is that l1 of F
times G is at most l 1 of f times l1 of
gl1 of F plus G is at most l 1 of f plus
l1 of G and then what you can what is
true is that a decision tree F with tea
leaves
as a 1 of f at most t even though when
you expand out this particular
polynomial you know when you start
expanding out you can imagine expanding
out a product of 1 minus X I you're
going to get many terms but the one norm
of this particular function it's not
difficult to see will be bounded by at
most T this is because each one of these
has one norm at most one when you're
taking a product a monomial is going to
have a 1 norm at most one and then
you're taking a sum and so you're going
to get l1 norm at most T and then what
you can say is that it's also an easy
fact that there exists a G a polynomial
such that G is l 1 of f reps of one of F
squared over epsilon sparse and the
expectation of G minus f squared is at
most epsilon so you give me a function
whose l1 norm is bounded there exists a
function G that is sparse in this sense
and closely approximates F in l2 and g
is simply F where you zero out all of
the the coefficients of the polynomial
that have magnitude less than epsilon
over l1 not difficult to see so I was
being sloppy and I was interchanging the
notion of bounded l1 norm and sparsity
but for the purposes of learning with
respect to the uniform distribution
there in some sense equivalent ok so
that's one correction I wanted to make
another thing I should have mentioned
this is regarding or I wanted to mention
mansoor's conjecture I'll just remind
you this is the conjecture that for any
dnf formula with s terms there exists a
polynomial P such that expectation of F
minus B squared most epsilon and let's
just say the one norm of P is at most s
to the order log 1 over epsilon what I
should have said I mean this is the
correct conjecture what I wanted to say
is that it's known and Men sort prove
this himself that you can construct a P
so there exists a P so that the one norm
of P is at most s to the log log s times
log 1 over epsilon
so you know we're pretty close to
solving I mean you know it's not too far
off and another thing I wanted to say
although I won't get into this at all is
that the man source conjecture is
implied by the entropy influence
conjecture
and since I don't want to get into what
the entropy influence conjecture is if
you're familiar with the notion of the
entropy of a boolean function and the
total influence of a boolean function
the conjecture is simply that the
entropy of a boolean function is always
less than or equal to some constant
times its total influence and it turns
out that if this conjecture is true man
source conjecture is an easy consequence
so you know if you can find a
counterexample to mentors conjecture
you'll disprove the entropy influence
conjecture so it's still and there are
also some learning applications that
will be able to talk about after I do if
they're talking about learning with
noise some more today okay so these are
the two things i wanted to mention and
then someone else suggested that if the
viewers at home want to email me a
question I will take a break in about an
hour and check my email you can email me
at Clive ins gmail com I'll check my
email and if i have any interesting
questions or if i have any questions at
all i will mention them about an hour
into the lecture take a very very small
break yes absolutely and though I know
your emails will not be of a technical
nature okay
yes to be true for said some rhythm oh
yeah okay so okay so I wrote a paper
with Holman Lee and andrew juan andrew
is here I think well maybe not are you
here injury now he was here yesterday
and what we prove what is there is sort
of a cute proof that if the dnf formula
is read once so each variable literally
appears once then the entropy influence
are then the mentors conjecture is true
if you do more work you can improve this
to read k for k constant and you know
what we also proved is that if you
choose a dnf formula at random and we
consider several different models of
choosing a dnf formula random pick any
kind of natural way you would choose a
dnf formula random the mentors
conjecture is going to be true do you
want me to briefly mention why this is
true or i can do it in two minutes so i
can give you a feel for what for why
it's true so maybe this is slightly
interesting so imagine you had a dnf
formula let me give you a very specific
data formula so x 1 and x 2 and x log in
or
x log n plus 1 or ok so i'll have say
let's say n terms each of length log in
roughly the tribes yeah ok so so the
probability that any one term say the
fixed term is satisfied is 1 over N and
an expectation so the expected number of
terms satisfied is one and furthermore
the probability that more than say log 1
over epsilon terms the probability that
any one of these is satisfied is 1 over
N I have n terms not n over log in I'm
doing yeah yeah and login variables yeah
the probability that more than log of 1
over epsilon terms is satisfied is it
most Epsilon ok now so consider the
following just univariate polynomial at
0 it will be 0 and then I'm going to
interpolate it so that
at all of these discrete values up to
log 1 over epsilon the polynomial is
exactly one ok and then so you know I
don't know what the polynomial is going
to do after after you go beyond log 1
over epsilon it's probably going to
increase dramatically and I'm not
interested in what it does over here but
i do want to assure that there's some
polynomial let's say gee that
interpolates 01 to log 1 over epsilon
appropriately and then I'm going to
consider the following polynomial that
is just g of t 1 i'm going to view t 1
is a monomial I'm just going to multiply
all of the variables together g of t 1
plus TN and so what you know when this
sum is 0 g is going to be 0 because we
interpolated that particular value when
this sum is between 1 and log 1 over
epsilon g is going to be exactly one so
it completely agrees with this
polynomial whenever the sum is between 0
and logwood for epsilon and then gar you
know when this sum is greater than log 1
over epsilon but the point is that that
happens with low probability so you can
just compute that the expectation of G
minus F squared is it most epsilon or
it's going to be some function of
epsilon you can choose epsilon
appropriately and also the degree of G
is log 1 over epsilon because it's
roughly blog whatever epsilon because we
only interpolate it about log 1 over
epsilon values so when you expand out
this polynomial
it's not difficult to see that it
satisfies the conditions for men source
conjecture this is the simple idea maybe
the most interesting thing about it is
that it does not it you can prove that
mentors conjecture is true for this dnf
without doing sort of the more standard
kind of 48 tricks on the boolean
function it's more just a question about
polynomial interpolation and then if
you'd like to recapture these other
results r EK and also if the dnf formula
is random you need to prove some sort of
concentration that with high probability
not too many terms of a dnf of that for
more satisfied and it's not too
difficult to do for the random case it's
for some reason it was very tricky for
the read k case but that's the main idea
let's see so
let me summarize what we discussed last
time it was we considered the following
optimization problem we wanted to
minimize over so we fixed a boolean
function and we wanted to minimize
overall p such that l1 of p is at most t
we wanted to approximately minimize the
expectation of p minus f squared and we
saw that we could do this the learner
needs queries F and this was a result of
khushi's of its immense or okay so
another interesting optimization problem
that you might consider instead of
putting this constraint on the
polynomial would be that you want to
minimize overall polynomial such that
the degree of the polynomial is at most
D expectation of p minus f squared so
here we're trying to minimize with
respect to sparse polynomials here we
want to minimize with respect to low
degree polynomials and this is the
there's a simple algorithm for doing
this this is the low degree algorithm of
lineaments or nissan and the learner
will not
need query access so again we can assume
that there's some fixed function f
instead the learner can just receive XF
of X rent passively randomly chosen
examples on the other hand whereas this
was a polynomial time algorithm in all
of the parameters polynomial in one over
epsilon and T and this algorithm will be
polynomial in n to the d + 1 over
epsilon okay so they're just
incomparable setups in the case when we
are optimizing when we were trying to
find the best fitting sparse polynomial
it was clear that what you should do is
take the largest Fourier coefficients
the largest coefficients of the
polynomial in this case again because we
have the plunger L equality or
parseval's equation we know that the
correct thing to do is take all degree d
or less of F's coefficients and by that
i mean when viewed
as a polynomial okay so remember you
know we know that f can be written as
some polynomial the coefficients are
these f hat a veces and if you want to
find the best degree D polynomial that
approximately minimizes sorry that
approximately minimizes this quantity
the correct thing to do is to output p
which is equal to the sum where the size
of s the size where you know is it most
d so we're only taking the degree D and
less coefficients I'm just claiming that
it's it's easy to see that this is the
best fitting degree D polynomial because
of parseval's equation now remember we
need to actually output we know this is
the correct polynomial how do we find it
in this case when the polynomial was
sparse we had to do this searching over
prefixes of coefficients here the
algorithm is simpler
we will enumerate so the algorithm we
will enumerate all monomials KS with s
less than D and estimate f hat of s and
remember that f hat of s equals the
expectation of f of x times k s of X
okay so given random examples we don't
need query access to F anymore give it a
random examples x from minus 1 1 to the
N I can you know you know i'll take my
random examples and labels and i'll see
you know approximately what is the
correlation of my function with this
particular monomial KY s that will give
me a good additive estimate of what F
hat of s is and then I'll just output
sign
maybe I'll call these this is the
estimated f hat of s and this will be my
output hypothesis
if you've seen this before I mean as
always like bear with me there's a
reason why I'm sort of spelling it out
this way
okay and then one of the you know what I
guess the next question is what sort of
functions can you learn using this type
of low degree algorithm so what
functions are learnable using this
algorithm well to that end we say that a
function f is epsilon D concentrated if
the sum
of all the coefficients on levels above
d some of their squares is it most
Epsilon okay so if a function is epsilon
D concentrated it means that the mass of
its spectrum above level d is at most
epsilon and therefore it suffice us to
estimate all of the Fourier coefficients
that lie all the coefficients on
monomials of size D or less so it's easy
to see that these functions will just by
definition these functions are exactly
the ones that are learnable by this type
of algorithm and then the next question
is so another interesting well I mean a
very interesting and fruitful framework
has been to find or prove that classes
of functions you know hopefully as large
as you can classes of boolean functions
are concentrated
and
the main result of lmn is that if F is a
size s step d circuit so this certainly
encompasses decision trees you know dnf
formulas would be depth to then f is
epsilon order log s over epsilon to the
D minus 1 times log 1 over epsilon
concentrated and Johan actually improve
this exponent to D minus 2 and this
immediately implies you know a quazy
polynomial time algorithm
for constant depth polynomial size
circuits also known as AC 0 and the main
technical tool which I will not at all
get into is a very beautiful
relationship between the effect that a
random restriction has on a circuit and
its ability to be concentrated as a
Fourier polynomial and so it's not
surprising that hofstede switching lemma
is at the center of it all here in this
result so I just wanted to mention this
particular application I'm not going to
get into the proof there okay so what I
would like to do now is show you how to
learn hunters because we've sort of
developed the technology and just recall
that a junta is a function minus 11 is a
boolean function that depends on only k
inputs k variables okay so one way to
think about a hunter or a k hunta is
that it's a polynomial
who's for a polynomial so the Fourier
polynomial for this hunter as it most
due to the K nonzero coefficients any
coefficient that involves a variable
that's not relevant to the function will
be zeroed out and each coefficient as
magnitude at least 1 over 2 to the K so
you know we've talked about finding
polynomials the coefficients for
polynomials or estimating their
coefficients here the difficulty is that
you're trying your given random access
to this hunta that only depends on K
input so you can think of it as a
polynomial with 2 to the K nonzero
coefficients and you're just trying to
find the goal is to just find some
nonzero coefficient it's hidden
amongst all of these you know
potentially I mean you may need to
naively you could just ask you can try
all to to the end coefficients and see
if any of them is nonzero there you know
2 to the K of them sitting there that
you need to find yet every coefficient
has magnitude at least 1 over 2 to the K
every nonzero coefficient has magnitude
at least one over to the gate I mean so
yeah I mean there's sort of it's like a
granularity issue here ok so the naive
algorithm so just take my word for it
that this problem the learning hook this
problem does indeed reduce to finding
some nonzero coefficient of this
polynomial that computes the K Hunta and
so the naive way of solving this problem
would be to just enumerate overall
degree ok or less monomials and estimate
its coefficient
and this algorithm will take time
roughly order n to the K to enumerate
overall monomials of degree care less x
2 to the K I may need to use this many
samples to estimate I mean if it's as
small as 1 over 2 to the K I'm going to
need roughly two to the K samples just
to see that it's nonzero and let me
remind you that we do not there's no
query access f it's easy to see that if
you have query access to f you can learn
hunters in polynomial time okay so as i
mentioned last time mossel o'donnell
answer video gave an end to the three
quarters k time algorithm this is
actually omega over omega omega plus 1
yep what k factorial in the denominator
it's okay i mean would it make you feel
better no wait what's the problem here
it's a most yes entry it's n choose k
which is at most n to the K Miami so no
way if you're consuming factoring
practice went on you and creator is a
case of dollar so choose Kate's not
estimate look that's high no no only I'm
not saying that this is incorrect Oh
trying to get strange oh you're saying
I'm overestimating here there isn't a
[ __ ] sure right but I do you mentioned
it due to the case oh yes oh okay
because yeah I did this because um
you'll see in a second winding ok i just
wanted to point out okay you're right
and what i wanted to point out is that
that in order to the sample complexity
for every coefficient is it most two to
the K that will come into play in a
second so good so let me show you this
this result and as I said there's
there's an improvement by Greg valiant
that uses this as a subroutine and
improves upon it to get like n to the
point 68 k or something like that okay
so I need it in order to show you this
result which is actually very simple I
need to make a small digression and talk
about learning GF 2 polynomials so this
whole time we've been representing
functions as real polynomials it's also
true that every F and now I'll write it
as 0 1 to the n to 0 1 can be written
as a GF to polynomial of degree n at
most n so this is an easy fact you can
just interpolate all 2 to the n values
using an appropriate monomial so you
know when we were talking about Fourier
polynomials and we had these monomials
of degree n the product of all the
variables so when we're working in with
respect to GF 2 polynomials of course
this becomes x1 plus x2 plus xn
so here's a question for you so you have
an unknown parity function so it's some
some of some it's some some mod 2 of
some subset of these variables call it f
and you want to learn what f is given
random examples labeled by
okay so you know the unknown parody
could be x 1 x or x for x or x 67 you
know you don't know what it is but what
you're given our random examples labeled
according to some unknown parity
function and you're asked to figure out
what the unknown parity is and it's so
for someone who hasn't seen this before
do you know what the algorithm is to
figure out what the unknown parity
function is okay yeah I guess you hon
sort of mentioned it yesterday I can
view you know I can view each one of
these as a linear equation mod 2 okay so
this corresponds to a 2 plus a 4 plus a
5 equals 1 this is all mod 2 and I'm
these AIS or kind of the coefficients of
the variables in the parody this one is
a 1 plus a 3 plus a 60 and so on and so
forth and I know that there is a
solution to this system so I you know
this induces a system of linear
equations
on two and I can find a solution you
know so i can find a solution to the
system of equations and that solution
will be consistent with all of the
random examples that I've seen so this
okay and if you remember from last time
if you take a large enough set of random
examples and you can find a solution or
some hypothesis in this case a solution
to the system of equations that's
consistent with all of these random
examples then it's easy to prove that
this hypothesis will generalize well so
this this really is the correct you know
this really will be an accurate
hypothesis so it's okay so it's it's
it's well known and it's easy to find to
learn an unknown parody function and now
I want to consider the following
generalization so let F be a degree d GF
2 polynomial in this case the degree of
F was one but here i have f it's a
degree d GF 2 polynomial claim is that F
and be learned
in time roughly order n to the 3d and
this is a simple trick that i'll refer
to as feature expansion
so if F is a degree d GF 2 polynomial
then it has at most n to the D terms
and so i can write it as a sum of N to
the D new variables
where I have a new variable for each
unknown coefficient of F so just like in
the degree D equals one case I had n
coefficients corresponding to the
unknown coefficients of the unknown you
know linear polynomial over GF to that I
was searching for if I have a degree d
GF 2 polynomial then it has at most n to
the D terms and I can come up with a set
of n to the D new variables each one
corresponds to one of these unknown
coefficients and the nice thing is that
then this reduces to learning parody
over n to the D variables and certainly
I can solve a system of n to the D
linear equations in n to the D variables
in time end to the 3d this is linear is
a realization i call it feature
expansion for because when I hopefully
will get to kernel methods well you're
kind of introducing a new feature ah
yeah I guess you could call it I think
it may be in some circles is referred to
linearization but Pat you know each each
one of these new coefficients I consider
a feature of the original space
okay good so the last thing we'll need
for learning hunters is this result due
to seek and dollar have a short question
yes so is there a small fact that you
swept under the rug that in the in the
first case with both parody this matrix
is filling up we perfectly understand
and invest can analyze and here it is a
little bit different more difficult than
therefore it's into the 3 D&M to the
three to the T oh no I'm just saying
that you know this could be like you
know using faster matrix Moulton I mean
there's some complexity here for solving
a system of linear equations oh but the
number of stamps is still something that
into the DES yes so the point is right
so there is sort of something I'm silly
you know the number of samples you need
to kind of get an accurate hypothesis
before you generalize in order to get
generalization power of your hypothesis
for a parody you need you know at least
n examples in order to get kind of
generalization power for a degree D
polynomial you can imagine it's going to
be larger I mean I how much longer is it
it's exactly n to the D I want the
matrix to be flowed rang right it
doesn't know it doesn't matter what it
doesn't matter you can output any any
any solution that's consistent with your
system of equations oh that's the
definition of the test well that's in
order to learn if you may so recall from
last time I said all you need to do in
order to learn is take a sufficiently
large set of examples and find a
consistent hypothesis with that set of
examples so take a sufficiently large
system of equations output any
consistent solution it will generalize
it's there's a difference between like
you know exactly solving a system of
linear equations and learning there's a
subtle difference but in parity isn't it
likely either a learner perfectly or I
offered a parody that's uncorrelated for
the uniform distribution yes but this
could be an arbitrary distribution
good question okay so the last fact
we'll need which was rediscovered I mean
it was discovered by a muscle o'donnell
answer video and they real they
discovered later that it was already
known so they reproved it it's a it's a
cute result it basically says basically
says if F is such that F hat of s is
equal to 0 for all s less than or equal
to D then the degree of f as a GF 2
polynomial is it most n minus d
okay so you can sort of see already that
we're in good shape here you know
remember you're searching for just one
nonzero fourier coefficient and what
this structural theorem says is that
well if all of the low-order fourier
coefficients are 0 then it's actually
computed exactly by a low degree GF 2
polynomial so f could be the parity
function yep so all if it's the parity
function all of its lower door
coefficients are 0 all n minus 1 degree
n minus 1 or less or 0 but it is a
degree n into it's a degree one GF 2
polynomial and minus DC's will be bored
yeah DS n minus 1 in that case
so the degree is if it's a parent
function that if it's a parody function
then it sits for a polynomial as a it as
a real beaut as a real polynomial has is
0 for all s less than or equal to n
minus 1 so then this becomes so it's a
degree n minus n minus 1 degree one GF 2
polynomial okay so to see this I mean
the first thing so there's one fact that
the degree of f as a GF 2 polynomial is
always less than or equal to the degree
of f as a Fourier polynomial
so
so let F be such that I've had of s
equals 0 for all s less than or equal to
D and then consider g which is equal to
the parody on all so I want to take the
parity on all I'm and bits times F and
then G
so just cool prudently yeah so right
that's what I'm trying to do so g is the
complement of F so G hat of s is going
to be 0 for all s greater than n minus D
so the GF 2 x so the GF 2 degree of G is
going to be at most D
but notice that my yeah you're right
sorry but notice that the that the GF 2
degree of G equals the GF 2 degree of F
because in the GF 2 scenario i can write
G as x1 plus xn plus F and I haven't
increased the degree of G at all so the
GF 2 degree of G is n minus D it turns
out they're equal so the GF 2 degree of
f is at most n minus D stub yeah it's
not he said it's a simple
complementation this fact which fact oh
this one that's that's it's simple I
mean you can you can really just look at
the interpolating polynomial for F and
just mod out its coefficients we're
sorry you can you can you can take an
interpolating polynomial at 40 a
polynomial and mod out its coefficients
and that will get you a GF 2 polynomials
you can write you can write F's for you
a polynomial such that all of the
coefficients are integers and then you
can mod out everything by 2 you're sort
of a convenient transformation so the
basis is scary one instead of minus one
plus you are so to disappear exactly
instead of using minus 11 you use 0 1
you'll get integer coefficients and you
can not everything out
just like when we were doing decision
trees you know and I was writing things
as 1 minus x 1 x 1 minus x 2 x 1 minus x
3 plus something else i mean you can do
that for an arbitrary function expand
everything out you'll get all integer
coefficients okay so now so now we're
going to do is choose D to be a 3k over
4 so either we run the low degree
algorithm in time n to the 3k over 4
times 2 to the K to sample each
coefficient which is why i was saying i
mean if you don't have the suit of the k
if you have an end to the 3k before then
you get end to the 6k over eight and
then that just that destroys their bound
so so either you run the low degree
algorithm in this time or you learn it
as a GF 2 polynomial and again we'll
have n it remember it was AK junta so
it'll be K minus knee so we'll choose D
to be 3k over 4 so you'll get but
remember you have a 3 here because you
have to solve a system of equations so
this is low degree algorithm and n to
the 3k over for this is a GF 2
polynomial
so either you run this algorithm and you
find some nonzero coefficient that gives
you a relevant variable and you move on
or you learn it as a GF 2 polynomial
okay any questions on that you can
replace your quarters by Omega over
Omega plus 1 and as I said Greg valiant
has an improvement to that even so not
to take anything away from this result
it's very nice on the other hand it's
very very simple and you would think
that certainly certainly this should be
the right found there should be
something kind of more sophisticated
that we can do I think that Abram Blum
will give you five hundred dollars if
you can do time water n to the K over 2
this is still open it might be a hundred
dollars but now he sits 509 I can't
remember he wrote it down somewhere you
can look it up
okay so now I want to finally start
moving on to learning with noise oh
maybe this is a good time to check my
email see if anyone wrote me something
have to get out of airplane mode
mm-hmm
nope no emails so thank you all right
so remember this i don't know why i
erase this but
these are the two sort of optimization
problems that we know how to
approximately minimize this one needs
queries f this one just needs random
examples good so I want to so I want to
talk about something called agnostic
learning and you'll see why it's a noisy
model of learning in just a second so I
want to fix an arbitrary boolean
function and the analogy here is
remember when we were learning decision
trees f with some unknown decision tree
here f is totally arbitrary and then I'm
going to define a quantity aunt which is
going to be the minimum ok so i also
want to fix some concept class see here
you can think of see as being decision
trees if you like now i want to define a
quantity opt it's the minimum overall
C&C of the probability when X is chosen
from minus 11 then that f of X does not
equal C of X
so this is the error rate of the best
fitting concept C with respect to F okay
and then the goal of the learner output
H such that the probability that H of X
does not equal f of X is it the most ah
plus epsilon and you would like to run
in time polynomial in n 1 over epsilon
no oh well no that would be proper
agnostic learning but no I'm not going
to make that restriction so what's going
on here well you know imagine that
you're given access blackbox access to
some function f it's not computed by a
decision tree but there's a decision
tree that agrees with three-quarters of
its inputs in that case opt is one
quarter and it seems reasonable to ask
the learner to output a hypothesis that
has error at most one quarter plus
epsilon almost equivalently well in this
kit in this setting equivalently you can
think of an adversary who comes takes a
decision tree and adversarial e corrupts
one quarter of its inputs and then gives
you blackbox access to this corrupted
function another thing to notice is that
I could take a decision tree and well
you know my function f could be
completely random on
an opt fraction of the inputs and it
would be unreasonable for me to expect
to output a hypothesis that has error
rate less than opt if that fraction of
inputs is chosen totally randomly good
so in the case that another thing to
notice is that opt equals zero is the
so-called is the pack setting this is
the setting we've been working in
yesterday and for the first half of
today if op 20 this means that actually
is a concept in your class that agrees
with F
okay and an even more general way to
define this would be to fix a
distribution d a joint distribution fix
a Class C and to define opt to be the
minimum overall C&C of the probability
when X Y is chosen the Dean doesn't
necessarily have to be uniform anymore
that ok so there's thanks
so here we fixed an actual function and
you thought of an adversary is
corrupting some opt fraction of inputs
here I'm just saying there doesn't even
need to be a fixed function involved it
could just be any joint distribution D
on your input space times the label
space and we can still define opt
according to this definition also
there's no I mean this could have been
and this could have been an arbitrary
spinning I mean this could have been for
example RN it didn't have to be the
discrete cube and later we'll be working
over RN
and so I think it's a very clean
formulation it has a lot of nice
advantages you may be familiar with
something called classification error
that's where imagine you're given a
decision tree and each label is
independently corrupted with some
probability data that is an easier model
than this setting and for various
reasons well for various reasons that
will see very soon this has a lot of
this model has a lot of appealing
features it's it's typically attributed
to the definition is typically a tribute
attributed to kearns Shapira and celly
from 93 though actually David Haussler
defined essentially defined this model
there was a very small twist that KSS
had in 91 and this model in a way also
goes back to the statistical learning
theory work of vapnik it actually
predates the pack model he was actually
interested in given a sequence of random
examples what is the best fitting
classifier that you can find on this
sequence of labelled random examples
where as sort of for valiance pack model
you always assume that there's some
concept there's some concept that labels
all of the points consistently one nice
thing about having an algorithm that
works in the agnostic setting is that
it's very robust so you know you give me
an arbitrary function as long as there's
some decision tree that you know is
reasonably correlated with F my learning
algorithm is going to do something
reasonable in the pack model if you have
an algorithm for you know learning a
decision tree and then you get like you
know some say you see one example that's
noisy then all bets are off as to what
your algorithm is going to do it could
just totally fail
so that's historically what happen so
now what I want to talk about is an
observation I will include the
quantification of a probability
distribution is it like an act yeah
sorry it's like impact you should have
an algorithm if you have an algorithm
that for so first I guess you fix the
concept class that you want to be
competitive with and then you should
succeed you should have an algorithm
that succeeds with respect to every
distribution and I guess you know one
thing that will be looking at is
distribution specific agnostic learning
and this will correspond to the case
when the marginal distribution on for
example minus 1 1 to the N is uniform
for example on minus 1 1 to the end this
is the case when x is the hypercube or
we could say D of X is Gaussian or
whatever other condition you'd like and
then that sort of corresponds to a case
where you're getting these random
examples the location of the points of
the randomly labeled examples are from
some distribution that you're aware of
the label is completely adversarial one
annoying thing about agnostic learning
is that it's difficult for example you
know one of the simplest problems in
pack learning that I can think of is
learning an unknown disjunction
okay so you're you know there's some
unknown disjunction you're trying to
learn and you get a bunch of examples
from some arbitrary distribution on say
0 1 to the N labeled positively if your
disjunction labels it positively and
negatives false on this particular
example and then you're asked to come up
you know figure out what the disjunction
is it's easy to see how to learn a
disjunction in the pack model every time
you have a negative example and for any
bit here that's one that means that that
literal cannot be in your disjunction
and so you can eliminate it from the
disjunction it's there's ave it's very
simple to learn disjunctions with
respect to arbitrary distributions on 0
1 to the N but agnostic alee learning
disjunction 'he's seems much harder so
in the agnostic learning disjunction
case you're given these you know with
where the marginal distribution could be
anything you're given these randomly
labeled examples you'd like to output
the best fitting disjunction on these
randomly labeled examples we know how to
solve this problem in time to to the
square root of n log 1 over epsilon I
think and that's that's the best
algorithm so we go from something like
very very simple to something quite
difficult you can show that this problem
of agnostic allele earning a disjunction
is actually harder than pack learning
dnf formulas so it's so it's not
surprising that you know we don't know
how to beat the best balance for
learning dnf formulas but yeah so it's
it's sort of a sort of a very difficult
model of learning even these simple
problems turn out to be quite tricky and
so that's why we're going to need to
make assumptions on the youth on the
distribution the marginal distribution
of the space
ah but you know we have to do something
we have to do something uh I mean you
can always do brute-force search but no
no yeah I so to compare to the to the
algorithms he have shown us before
checking your email a Saudi and some of
them we just stood for example the
Fourier coefficients by drawing random
samples right with optimum if the
optimum is small here just shifts the
work right okay so that's what I was
about to talk about so that's that's a
good question so you know so question
one let's say F is epsilon D
concentrated okay so the students
so C is a class such that every C and C
is epsilon D concentrated ok good so
let's run even though we're in so let's
assume that D of X is uniform over minus
1 1 to the N ok so good let's just run
let's run the low degree algorithm and
see what happens so so now we have
access to some distribution on its
uniform on minus 1 1 to the N it's a
joint distribution on that x minus 1 1
and so let's try and minimize the
expectation X Y drawn from minus 1 and
minus 1 one of over all polynomials p3e
of y minus p of x squared ok
and let's say that C will say C
corresponds to best fitting concept
see
so
so right so this is going to be less
than or equal to so you know just to be
concrete I'm given a bunch of randomly
labeled examples and I'm going to run a
low degree algorithm and it will output
some P of X this is the you know best
fitting polynomial in l2 that I can find
given my sequence of random examples now
this is going to be less than
since my algorithm you know finds the
best fitting polynomial P this quantity
is you know approx let me just say this
for a second it's it's going to be
certainly less than the air if you would
outputted the actual for a polynomial of
C hat so here here's a polynomial that
you could have output you're going to
output the the one that minimizes this
quantity this is going to be less than
or equal to expectation over X and Y of
Y minus C I think I get a 2 here y minus
C squared plus C minus squared
so I'm using the almost triangle
inequality here so I lose a factor of
two because I'm adding and subtracting
see and everything is squared now this
term here we know is I think two times
Epsilon this is because we said that C
is concentrated and every time why
remember y is plus 1 minus 1 C is plus 1
minus 1 every time they disagree you're
going to get a 2 in here and when you're
going to square that you'll get a 4 so
you'll end up with eight times the
probability over XY that C of X does not
equal Y and this is opt so you'll get 8
opt + 2 times epsilon
now for whatever reason and we were we
made this observation and we were
working with Shimon sore who's the m
from lmn he claimed that he did not was
not aware of this I don't know that it
has this sort of noise tolerant property
you know you would really like to you
know what you really want is opt +
Epsilon with no constant out here why
well I mean if you give me access to a
function and say there's a decision tree
that agrees with three-quarters of it
then opt is a quarter this bound is
meaningless it's it's error is still
eight times a quarter and something
greater than one okay so so it's nice
that it has some kind of weak agnostic
property but what you'd really like is
off to plus epsilon and you can also
show that in the case when you would
like to you know agnostic allele earn
decision trees you'd like to output the
most competitive function here with
decision trees the same thing holds if
you run the sparse algorithm it has some
weak agnostic some weak noise tolerant
properties and you also get like eight
times out plus epsilon now we can fix
this so the way to fix this is instead
of minimizing this quantity with a
square which just minimize this quantity
and that's going to get rid of the
squares
oh yeah hold on I can't get rid of that
and this will this will end up with two
opt I don't worry I can take care of
this but you'll end up with two opt + 2
epsilon and then if instead of
outputting the sign of P of X you out
put the sign of P of X minus theta you
can choose theta randomly this is a
little trick taking your polynomial P
and then choosing a random sign will
actually save you another factor of two
and then what you need to do you
actually need you actually need if you
want to run this algorithm with the one
norm instead of the two norm you need
this to be epsilon squared concentrated
because then you'll get this is epsilon
sorry I'm gonna use glossary snorts ah
yeah yes exactly ok so the kind of
simple observation is that you know
shifting from minimizing from the two
norm to the one norm gave you gives you
this strong agnostic property and you
know what you'll need if you want to
minimize with respect to the one norm is
just a little bit more concentration in
order to get all of this to work now
then the next question is what's the
complexity of expectation of min p
degree d Y minus P of X
and the complexity it turns out that
this can be written as an LP with order
n to the D variables and order n to the
D constraints
okay so just like in the low degree
algorithm you pay it exponentially
indeed here you're also going to pay
exponentially in D and then you're going
to have to run an LP solver to do this
minimization whereas the algorithm from
element was very very simple it just
involved random random sampling so
already you can see that the complexity
of the algorithm involved to do this
sort of minimization when you get rid of
the 2 norm because you lose really
because you lose parts the vols equation
goes up dramatically but it still runs
in polynomial time and then and this is
sort of the most more interesting
question what happens if you want to
find your given query access to a
function f and so in order to do
agnostic learning you can do the same
proof but it suffices to do this
minimization expectation of the absolute
value of F minus P where P is sparse
this is more complicated
because you still want to run in time
polynomial in n + 1 over epsilon and T
but it's not clear now that you should
just take the strangely it's it's not
clear that you should just take the
largest coefficients we believe it's not
true that you should take the largest
coefficients I mean you will get
something like 8 or 4 times off plus
epsilon but if you really want up plus
epsilon I don't think you can just run
the km algorithm but I don't have a
proof that you can
so what I want to tell you about is the
complexity of this problem so
approximately so you've fixed an
arbitrary boolean function and you want
to approximately minimize
this quantity
is it clear on what kind of quantity we
want to approximately minimize so a
couple of observations here one the set
of all P such that the one norm of P is
bounded by T its convex ok so the
underlying set that you're optimizing
over is convex that's good and also the
coup shoot of its immense or algorithm
the Candace parse algorithm sort of can
returns polynomials from within this
convex set
so you know I have some have some
polytope here and I'm trying to minimize
this particular quantity another good
thing I know is that you know think of
teas being polynomial in n if I were to
expand out this minimization is a linear
program there would be two to the n
variables and two to the n constraints
you know so if I if I were to try and
solve it explicitly it would take too
much time but I know the diameter of
this convex set is it most T and you
know I'm trying to minimize some
particular function here furthermore
when i run the km algorithm it's good
you know as we said it outputs a
hypothesis that is a sparse polynomial
so it's going to output some particular
point here in the convex set and then
sort of what we could hope to do is
implicitly approximate the gradient and
do some sort of projected gradient
descent
within the polytope within the convex
set so the hope is that you could
implicitly solve this minimization
problem using the km algorithm and
Oracle access to f as some way to kind
of locally see where you are in the
convex set and kind of move you know
move in the opposite direction of the
gradient do gradient descent and if you
get outside of the convex set then kind
of implicitly project back into the
convex set it turns out you can do this
and this is what we did with park should
go felan and adam kalai but i'm not
going to talk much about it because i
think it would take up too much time but
i'll just say that it can be done there
yes well actually it will take so
basically you use km to estimate the
gradient then you walk in that direct in
the opposite direction and then after
you've made this step you may now be
outside of the the convex set and
there's a simple way to project back
into the convex set and then you'll use
km to estimate the gradient again and
repeat and the fact that it converges
critically uses the fact that the
diameter of the convex that is not too
large so there were two subsequent works
one by kalai and kana day Varun is here
and one by natalia Feldman and they both
gave simpler proofs of this result using
boosting and actually that i should say
they use something called agnostic
boosting
and there's they're very nice and
there's a very cool though these
agnostic boosting items have some very
very cool properties so what what I
wanted to do because it allows me to
kind of give a digression I mean there
you know no mini-course on learning can
go without you know mentioning boosting
so it allows me to kind of give a small
digression on to boosting and then talk
about the sort of agnostic boosting that
they that they do and and kind of at a
very high level explain to you why you
can use this to minimize this problem
okay so just as with the low degree
algorithm when you put when you made
this a 1 the algorithm became more
complicated you have to use linear
programming when you make this when you
when you minimize with respect to the
one norm here the algorithm again at
least even the simplified versions are
still in my opinion quite a bit more
complicated than cushy limits immense or
algorithm so in the five minutes I have
left
I wanted to quickly define a boosting
algorithm and then when we start
tomorrow I'll show you a boosting
algorithm that you haven't seen before
most likely it's very very slick and it
has a self-contained analysis so you'll
totally understand how to do boo state
in the standard setting and then I'll be
able to describe how to do boosting in
the agnostic setting so so we're working
let's say back in the pack model so
there's a concept C and C but labeling
all of our examples there's no noise we
say that a is a weak learner this is
weak learner or see if for every
distribution d given access to random
draws from d
a outputs and hypothesis H such that the
probability when X is chosen from D that
H of X let's fix an unknown concept
little see that H of X because I should
say let's say equals C of X is at least
one-half plus gamma okay so in the
typical pack scenario you you want your
hypothesis to be you want this to be 1
minus epsilon let's imagine instead that
you have some primitive known as a weak
learner that instead only gets you one
half plus gamma so imagine it's correct
only fifty one percent of the time but
it works for all distributions d and a
boosting algorithm
takes an algorithm a it's a weak learner
and it produces an algorithm a prime
that's a strong learner so it's a
reduction that uses this weak learner as
a subroutine and is can use that to
output a hypothesis that really is 1
minus epsilon accurate and at a very
high level so you can imagine draw you
can imagine drawing a set of random
examples you know and so here are your
random examples and you would like to
find a hypothesis H that is 1 minus
epsilon accurate and instead so they're
drawn from some distribution d call it D
1 so you have these points labeled
alright you output a hypothesis that
gets say these points correct and these
points incorrect
and then what a typical boosting
algorithm will do is form a new
distribution d2 and it will put more
weight so it will increase weight on
these points that were incorrectly
labeled by your hypothesis and it will
decrease the weight on these points that
were labeled correctly by your
hypothesis and that will correspond to a
new distribution d2 and then it will run
the weak learner with respect to this so
with respect to d1 it had this original
hypothesis it'll it'll run the week
later again simulating this new
distribution and that will force it to
output a weekly accurate hypothesis and
because we increase the weight on the
points that we were wrong that will
force this week learner to kind of do
better on these points that that the
original hypothesis was wrong and we'll
continue this process and you have to do
it in a somewhat clever way and then as
you can imagine if you take a weighted
majority of all of these weak learners
that you've output you can prove so Rob
superior was the first to prove that
doing this type of thing will result in
a strongly accurate hypothesis and it
also turns out that should just mention
that I'm not too concerned with how
these algorithms that I've been
describing right now perform in practice
but boosting has been a real success
story and is used in practice all the
time you can imagine running some kind
of heuristic that gets you kind of
fifty-three percent accurate on your
data set and then trying to apply some
boosting algorithm and rerunning the
heuristic and that's what people do and
it works extremely well so next time
what I'll do is I'll show you how this
works using an algorithm that you
probably haven't seen before and then
we'll move to the agnostic boosting
scenario and I'll describe how you can
use that to solve this minimization
problem
and then we'll move on to learning we'll
move on to some convex geometry that's
it thanks